when you take a step back and really
think our world is amazing we have all
of the world's knowledge at our
fingertips AI if they can mimic thinking
and do things well beyond our wildest
expectations a 100 year old industry
being disrupted by electric cars but how
did this all come to be well we have to
go back to the beginning these
innovations didn't come out of nowhere
there are incredible stories and
personalities behind everything we have
James Watt to thank for having food to
eat that we didn't grow ourselves a bed
to sleep on and every mass produced good
we have Michael Faraday and Nikola Tesla
to thank for our electricity
it was Wilbur Wright that observed the
birds in the air and gave us flight we
have Vannevar Bush and Tim berners-lee
to thank for the Internet Douglas
Engelbart to thank for the mouse and
graphical competing it was Edie cap
Mills class project that gave us the
birth of CGI movies Larry page's
midnight train gave us Google Einstein's
genius gave us GPS accuracy Wayne West
immense risk condition gave us the
iPhone and the ease of use than all of
our smart phones Geoffrey Hinton's
persistence gave us the AI revolution
and of course there's much much more
some of these names and stories you may
have never heard before but one thing is
true they're all simply amazing I just
want to quickly read out one early
review that I've gotten about the book
when I read it it just made me
appreciate my life so much afterwards so
much so that I cried and joyfulness this
book showed that we are much more
capable than what we think we're capable
and that right there is what the book is
meant to do you'll have a new
appreciation for humanity a real sense
of how a world came to be and the secret
stories of those who built it the new
thinkers some eternally praised some
eternally forgotten the tireless work
the conflicts the sorrow and the joy
it's new thinking the story of us
cold fusion its rethinking
you